we're in Russia where a weird waterspout
is heading straight for this raft nature
does some crazy stuff hold on to your
hats these guys seem very pleased with
their meteorological encounter what
exactly is this wet and wild weather
event this spinning vortex is a dust
devil which is moved out off the land
and over the water
it's now a water devil dust devils form
on hot cloudless days when one part of
ground heats up more than the
surrounding area and that warms the air
above it and the hot air begins to rise
punch it through the colder air if the
column of hot air is hit by a side wind
coming in at just the right angle it can
start the column rotating but because
the column is also rising and being
stretched out it is becoming thinner and
that decrease in the diameter of the
column can cause the spinning action to
be intensified the dust devil is
spinning at 40 miles an hour 70 km/h
that's plenty enough to pick up surface
water spray it over the rafters and blow
off their hats